donc en février 2021 que coline berry
accuse son père richard berry de
violences sexuelles qu'elle aurait subis
mineure à l'époque où richard vivait
avec vous une chine l'a aussi accusé
publiquement jean de complicité dans un
article du monde à l'accuse de l'avoir
poussé à de parts à participer à des
jeux sexuels je rappelle que vous avez
porté plainte pour diffamation vous avez
gagné votre procès
quand vous avez appris ces accusations
comment vous avez pris ces accusations
zi6 déjà je les ai appris sur le dans le
monde le journal le monde ces derniers
qui vous ont rappelé qu'ils vous m'ont
dit on t'accuse ou bien d'un coup j'ai
appris ça comme ça
quelque chose que je n'avais jamais fait
sécession parce que je n'ai jamais fait
du mal à cet esprit art et puis elle
accuse elle nous accuser d'être tous
ensemble
des choses qui étaient quand même
aberrant avec ma fille shirel et avec
richard et rien de ça s'est passé donc
j'étais obligé de me battre comme jamais
je me suis battu dans ma vie pour dire
la vérité pour éveiller à joindre de lui
parler ou pas du tout tendance avait
séduit parler de la joindre que non pas
du tout je n'ai jamais été j'ai essayé
de la parler avant elle venue je l'avais
pas rencontrée depuis 35 ans et puis un
jour et elle s'est élevée ni voir ma
fille shirel d'abord près on a déjeuné
après un an s'est passé et puis et puis
tout d'un coup je me vois dans le
journal donc c'était quand même très
choquant et comme géraldine et l'a dit
très bien et je l'appréciais beaucoup
elle a dit non c'est pas son histoire et
donc ça m'a donné beaucoup de
et je vous remercie parce que ça m'a
donné beaucoup de courage
ben est donc je senti quelqu'un qui me
croyais quelque part et donc
et donc après je
savais qu'avec mon manager sophie nous
avons récolté tout l'été mois qu'on
pouvait faire parce que moi je suis pas
quelqu'un qui
qui va la presse moi je préfère comme
shirel parler des belles choses parler
de la musique
je sais qu'il ya des choses terribles
qui se passe dans le monde mais c'est
pas mon histoire moi j'essaie de le
faire les meilleures choses pour tous
pour les autres et je vais continuer
richard je crois que c'est pareil jules
alors c'est vrai que dans la famille il
ya deux clans c'est formidable que vous
soyez là toutes les deux parce que
coline berry vous cite aussi chérel
vendent en scène marcial dit que vous
étiez jeune très jeune mais que vous
étiez là moi ce que je voudrais vous
poser comme question c'est pourquoi
colline berry aurait-elle tout inventé
c'est très précis les jeux sexuels des
jeux très précis en votre présence
marais sais pas pourquoi auraient-elles
toute éventuelle leur vie ont inventé
quelque chirac il y avait des gens qui
inventent des choses et plein de
shopwiki parce que c'est un mal être
parce que ça c'est un exutoire c'est
d'autres problèmes et qui se fonde sur
ça en tous les cas si on était quatre
dans cette pièce qu'elle décrit moi
j'étais donc de 0,5 j'avais 6 et 7 elena
v8 puisqu'on a un an différents et vous
mais ça c'est pas passé donc y'a rien
beaucoup richer parce que c'était un
mariage très compliquées entre il avait
avait beaucoup de passion et et beaucoup
de disputes donc en tant qu enfin c'est
s étaient houleux et donc un peu violent
pas dans les coups mais dans la lah la
forme de la passion la passion des
disputes et puis j'avais j'apprécié pas
beaucoup richard parce que c'est pas un
super beau père très affectif avec moi
donc voila quoi c'est tout c'est pour ça
que je l'aimé pas il m'a fait du mal
parce qu'il faisait du mal à la mer
jouer ma mère pleurait de ces de ces
disputes mais c'est tout cette eau vidéo
et on les a jamais revus d'ailleurs ni
richard nicoll et plus 40 ans ah oui
c'est une affaire qui s'est beaucoup
dérouler dans les médias le fossat
rendre la sphère publique c était le
monde on parle souvent de tribunal
médiatique qu'est ce que vous en voulez
aux médias pour la manière même si l'on
traité serait
sympa très jeu des juges c'est injuste
la médiane est pas un juge comme comme
quand vous non plus vous n'êtes pas des
juges et bosino je pense je crois
beaucoup dans la justice et enfin je
crois
très bonne justice je remercie la
justice en france qu étant américaine de
ma voix a pris pris au sérieux dans
cette affaire moi comme j'ai dit c'est
pas possible de changer mon histoire de
ce que j'ai pu faire dans ces pays je
suis obligé m de tout mon coeur chez
alcan quand vous avez vu ces accusations
écrite dans le monde vous appelez votre
maman vous avez dit quoi parce que vous
ce que vous êtes dit six essais c'est
une affaire incroyable qui nous qui nous
tombe dessus je faisais tu dis quoi
mais déjà j'ai pas compris l'ampleur
parce que j'habite à tel-aviv et donc on
était moins pas vous plutôt pas du tout
concerné entre guillemets on n'avait pas
les médias tout ça et j'ai appelé j'ai
dit écoute ce qui est important c'est
que nous on sache que c'est vrai nous la
famille ma soeur moi tes amis on s'en
fout du reste moi je suis un peu comme
ça dans ma vie personnelle dans ma
carrière je m'en fous un peu salée pour
essayer de joindre aux collines ou non
plus au nom moi ces collines qui m'a
fait qui m'a dit est ce que tu veux bien
témoigner avec moi dans le monde j
dhimmis mais pas du tout donc réduit
tout puisque moi c'est pas vécu ça je
vais pas non plus
témoigner en quelque chose que j'ai pas
vécu et elle avait demandé la même chose
à ma mère et parce que l'on n'a pas
soulevé n'a pas suivi si ça s'est passé
c'est ça se fait c'est quand elle a vu
ma mère au restaurant est lui tombé dans
les bras elle a dit qu'elle fait c'est
formidable de te voir jean l'a fait une
photo on était elle était heureuse de la
voir elle a dit
la meilleure femme qu'il a eue réchappa
ce que tu tenais tête parce que ma mère
sa femme de tête mais ça s'accroche on
nous dit ce soir parce que et donc elle
vous est donc à chercher avec elle en
fait nouvelle nous voulait avec elle
parce que vous n'aimez pas riche ou le
pauvre maintenant je m'entends très bien
avec un dossier aussi vide et nous
donnerions présent je suis moi je rentre
pas dans ces affaires oui si c'est
federer d'ockham donc n'ont pas été
jugées sûres
personnellement oui eux indépendamment
de ça moi je ne sais pas et voilà pour
l'instant ces statistiques stats on
travaille là dessus tf1 - richard c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours été très simple
très sympa avec moi avec qui je me suis
toujours bien entendu jean les plateaux
qui a toujours été voilà après voilà
c'est là où on parle de cette affaire
cette affaire veille du giron bas on
pense à ces terribles
nous encore c'est terrible pour ma mère
mais c'est richard le pire dans tout ça
c'est terrible pour lui c'est sa fille
pourquoi est ce qu'elle dirait ça c'est
après avoir il ya plein de gens qui vont
dire aussi c'est terrible pour coline si
les faits
c'est bien si j'étais pas dedans si
j'étais pas dans cette pièce qu'elle
décrit alors donc peut-être que c'est
arrivé on peut pas le savoir mais si jal
dit que j'étais dans la pièce et que
c'est arrivé avec moi alors moi je peux
le savoir non puisque j'étais là donc
moi je dis que c'était pas vrai certains
membres de la famille mêmes raisons à
kolin contre vider mon nom n'était pas
là oui même panier accord ça ça existe
et man et oui mais ce que disent ces
gens et ce que dit colline c'est que
toutes les deux un sikh richard berry
vous pourriez être dans le déni fallu
refuser même d'envisager tennis qu'est
ce qu'elle rien le mensonge et vous le
savoir les registres de l'austérité je
vous pose la question mais les juges et
la nuque alors le jeu vous avez vu
qu'elle a été ça a été jugé oui
là dessus sur jean manson nous avez vu
que voilà c'est
pour l'instant
en faveur en faveur de d'une absolue mal
absolu mission du sien c'est en faveur
de la wii guillaume tu parles d'une
justice appliquée guillaume parent d'une
justice médiatique mais c'est vraiment
collines qui a voulu que ce soit mais à
la place publique n'a pas été dedans une
juge je ne sais pas voilà donc avait
plus vraiment un tournant par là sur les
plateaux et je voulais savoir vous à
l'époque quand vous êtes avec richard
berry quelles sont vos relations puisque
vous disiez vous qu'elles n'étaient pas
bonnes avec richard berry qu'elle vous
et quelle relation vous aviez vous savez
moi je viens d'un autre pays
ggd autre façon de voir la vie richard
berry avait autre façon de voir la vie
je l'aimais beaucoup
mais on s'entendait pas sur beaucoup de
choses on avait des différends carrière
de chanteuse et il était comédien en
même temps c'est difficile donc parfois
la dent un couple qui lie à des tensions
népal avec sa fille avec colleen vous
avez des relations de quel ordre non
malades très bien meilleur que
finalement votre psy avec richard berry
oui oui mais si j'habitais avec mais je
ne croyais pas beaucoup
beaucoup pas beaucoup de toupin fait 20
fois dans ma vie ah oui fait tout ça a
duré un an et demi c'était très court
c'était pas beaucoup alors aujourd'hui
on s'est reconstruit mais coller
l'oreille colline aujourd'hui pour vous
c'est parce que c'est quelqu'un qui fait
un kick ils vous poussent ici qui a
menti c'est quelqu'un qu'on vingt
scellés jusqu il a dit c'est pas moi et
j'ai aujourd'hui je suis là oui je fais
suis allé voir le juge le juge nous a
donné raison et donc je suis très
heureuse aujourd'hui je respire un peu
même s'il y a une appel c'est pas ça ne
la vérité on le sait toujours est en
marche et normand et là nous pour
changer il chantait et puis on est venu
pour vous parler de ça il va pour été
victime aujourd'hui on est plus victime
revient me reconstruire ma vie vous
vivez aujourd'hui par don inouï j'essaie
de revivre jeu c'est très difficile d
oublier ça parce que c'est ce qu'on
tournait ont lâché de nous détruire et
nous salir mon nom havas après tout ce
que j'ai pu faire un don en france bon
ok je ne suis pas parfait tu peux avoir
des défauts mais mais pas des défauts
comme c'est horrible c'est lorient vous
avez votre donner votre sentiment sur ce
qu'elle dit sur vous et richard berry
est ce que vous avez un sentiment aussi
sur ce qu'elle dit sur sa relation avec
son père ou est-ce que vous ne
connaissez pas été là dès que je connais
pas ce que s'est passé pendant 40 ans je
ne les ai pas vus donc elle non plus
donc c'est quand même un peu tu vois
farfelues pour moi donc voila moi jamais
est ce que la relation qu'il avait avec
son père déjà été été tendu parce que ça
ressemble car on sait pas mais on
apprend qu'elle veut se venger de
quelque chose alors oui oui tout contre
vous voilà contre son père oui bmc bien
sûr mais après pas par la suite on a
pris on a appris son existence en chemin
c'est pas c'est pas un chemin facile
elle a sûrement eu des problèmes dans sa
vie quand elle était jeune avec sa mère
je sais pas c'est ce qu'elle maintienne
pas ça nous appartient pas oui on ait
jamais fait quoi que ce soit on a
l'impression que vous vous dites qu'est
ce qu'on vient fermer certains moments
ils disent qu'ils se souvient faire la
toilette ça c'est ça et oui on n'a rien
à voir là dedans et on incitait ses sa
piscine à
voir là dedans non musulmans on était
quatre dans cette pièce à la
photo que vous voyez derrière ça va être
jugé honteux
ce que je veux dire c'est que s'il
m'avait pas mis dans elle me parle elle
ne parle que de moi dans ces scènes je
suis avec elle elle elle me l'a dit tu
étais avec moi tu as fait si tu as fait
ça moi je me rappelais pas ça m'a prêté
2 [ __ ] on peut dire aussi vous êtes dans
un déni quant à lui nommé désir alors
seulement la css si je peux comprendre
de nos mairies sais pas mais moi
j'aimais pas du tout richard je me
rappelle de tout ce que j'aimais pas de
lui de tout mais traumatise que j'ai eue
avec lui qui n'ont rien à voir avec un
truc pervers de la piscine jamais réussi
à mettre la tête sous l'eau pendant 35
ans kim il m'apprenait à nager en me
jetant maxime comme ce qu'on faisait il
ya 40 ans sauf que moi je vais très mal
vécu et pendant 35 ans j'ai pas mis ma
tête sous l'eau font pareil avec des
requins dans la vie
je l'aimé vraiment pas quoi vraiment pas
donc j'avais j'ai tous les souvenirs
j'épluche une artiste je suis quelqu'un
de très sensible les enfants ils sont
très sensibles à la sexualité se
rappelle des choses même quand ils
comprennent pas ils savent qu'il ya un
truc on n'a pas le droit de dire et donc
sa somme oui c'est tough commun et bah
ça je m'en serais rappelé parce que ce
que je m'en rappelle d'autres hommes par
exemple qui vont dire des blagues
grivoises à table quand on est petit
mais on dit à devrait pas être là il ya
un truc bizarre pourquoi j'écoute ça on
est sensible à ça moi j'étais une enfant
très sensible il faut préciser que
parallèlement à votre victoire en
diffamation donc avec un appel il ya une
enquête qui se poursuit après la plainte
initiale de la brigade de protection des
mineurs oui j'y étais voilà voulez vous
avez été entendu en guinée après et vous
vous y allez bientôt mais voilà il ya
une date vous avez déjà la date de
convocation oui oui d'accord et dans le
dossier il ya quand même un élément que
je voulais confronter avec vos jeane
manson c'est que il figure votre
appartenance à l'époque à une secte la
secte des enfants de dieu c'est une
secte alors si cette américaine très
libérale où il ya eu des scandales de
pédophilie est ce que vous avez
appartenu à ce mouvement pas du tout
mais là on a la mer noire que non
justement la preuve que non et c'est
pour ça que j'ai gagné un diplôme à
derry alors le problème de tous cette
cour de choses c'est parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup d enfants qui
sont maltraités ok mais et qui disent
rien avec eux plus tard ils sachent et
ils se souviennent des choses ça je
l'avouer c'est terrible pour des enfants
est vraiment mais dans cette histoire là
c'est parole contre parole parce qu'il
ya prescription parce qu'elle a été
directement au monde le journal le monde
pour décrire tous ces trucs là plutôt
que d'y aller chercher un ami ça viendra
quand elle a dit sur bfm tv que
j'appartenais de
l'enfant de dieu je dire 5e merci
seigneur que je puisse aller maintenant
grâce à ça vous prouver que j'étais pas
dans une secte fin de semaine à prendre
j'ai toutes les preuves
du basket s est une lettre du boss de là
des enfants de dieu qu'il a maudit parce
qu'il dit jeane manson tu ne veux pas
partir à notre secteur ce maudit tu es
tu es marié avec un juif qui était mon
père tué une enfant rejeté de dieu tu te
souhaite tout ça parce que l a dit mais
moi je veux pas parler c'est des
musiciens qui travaillaient pour elle ça
veut pas dire quelque 200
démissionne de musiciens américains ont
ainsi été bon c'était mon père un
producteur de ses idées sincères mais la
bible que je voudrais vraiment est
d'accord voilà les rives de nom mais
j'écoute avec énormément d'attention
effectivement moi je vous le disiez
c'est parole contre parole et ce qui m'a
interpellé c'est lorsque vous avez dit
que vous aviez d'abord vu collines et si
je comprends ce que vous sous-entendez
c'est que parce que vous n'avez pas
voulu vous joindre à vous estimez que
c'est pour ça que nous visons mais
si j'étais très contente de la voir j'en
étais très content très content tout mon
avis une photo elle a dit tiens je vais
l'envoyer à mon père ça va lui faire les
pieds elle m'a fait un lcd ils ont été
très content de te revoir et puis voilà
donc et après un an plus tard je suis
dans le journal comme quoi j'ai fait des
horreurs à ce prix là et je ne serai
jamais fait des malades cette personne
au contraire quand j'étais quand elle
était jeune gg l'amener en amérique vois
ma mère je l'amenais en vacances parce
que j'ai travaillé dans la mine puis
vous maurice et du nous vous ils vous
disent quoi les gens dans la rue quand
ils vous reconnaissent au fond de
l'affairé que vous en parle ou pas du
tout les gens dans la rue vous en parle
ce que l'occident là je dois vous êtes
au courant très gentil laisserait au
théâtre actuellement est triste par la
fiche d'une pièce de diète aux côtés de
popeck qui extraordinaire elle adore
popeck qui s'appelle des larmes de
crocodile est ce que le public quand il
vient on voit aussi ce qu'ils vous ont
par la plainte pénale du tout c'est dans
quelques mois je monte sur scène et avec
beaucoup de peur que les gens y vont
bien sûr se sent aimé où ils vont pas
venir mais au contraire et ce plan les
s'est plaint le quand je chante bon on
sort de co vide ça recommence à pouvoir
chanter faire des galas mais c'est vrai
que j'avais très peur de monter après
pour d'être critiqué pour ça mais je
suis très sereine parce que je n'ai rien
fait de mal à cette personne et donc
quand tu as la vérité pour toi et que tu
sais que tu n'as rien fait tu peux te
battre jusqu'à la fin de ta vie et tous
les gens qui sont pris aujourd'hui qui
ont fait rien fait qu'ils ont été écrits
par coupe à 10 heures j'ai vraiment la
peine peur parce que c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui de dire la vérité
parce que la vérité parfois c'est sur
lyon il préfère d'avoir là les mensonges
pour pouvoir puisse y exercer plus sexy
oui on va décider à la justice est plus
facile à passer et vous shirel serré
c'est vrai que vous avez été me voilà
dans la sauce aussi voilà dans cette
affaire mais heureusement comme ça je
peux dire que c'est pas vrai et et vous
vous êtes dit je vais continuer à
chanter je vais fait un nouvel album sur
moi je suis on a fait des kimonos
one piece et wan lan
hyper positif et solaire non mais c'est
chic colline de palavas cutter et vous
fait un album c'était chose vous vous
dites nous on essaie 2 voilà on essaie
de de passer outre tout ça et de la vie
continue on veut bien évidemment est
formidable ça ne nous concerne pas donc
nous ce qui nous concerne c'est de
donner de créer et de partager
d'inventer de s'inspirer et locaux vides
a été propice à tout ça puisque
justement on avait le temps d'aller
chercher à l'intérieur ce qu'on avait
envie de dire donc que ce soit dans des
kimonos comme celui ci où enfin moi je
vais faire un nouveau délai fait enlever
le sourire et son mec
qu'on avance et coûté en tout cas